so today we're going to talk about the
problems with attempting to prevent a
heart attack now the worst thing you
want to run into is finding out the
solution to your preventing a heart
problem is causing a heart problem let
me show you what I'm talking about let's
see you have hypertension and you're on
a diuretic well the side effect of
diuretics is increasing insulin
resistance which actually could
potentially increase your insulin and
create more of a problem within your
arteries let's say for example you're on
cholesterol medication you're on a
statin statin increases the risk of
calcification in your arteries plus it
shuts down the testosterone and it can
decrease coenzyme q-10 which is needed
for the heart and here's another one
let's say you're on some anti-clotting
medication to thin the blood warfarin
which blocks vitamin K the problem with
that one is that it causes some side
effects one being increasing risk of a
calcification not just in the arteries
but systemically even in your trachea
because it blocks vitamin K k1 and k2
and just so you know vitamin k2 is all
about keeping the calcium out of the
arteries out of the soft tissues and
into the bone the longer you're on this
medication the greater the risk of the
calcium clogging everything up on the
arteries now out of all these problems
the most important thing to focus on is
making sure you do not build up calcium
plaque and the arteries why because the
amount of calcium in the arteries
specifically the coronary artery is the
biggest risk factor for mortality from
heart attacks and this is why one of the
most important tests that you can get
way more important than a cholesterol
test is a CA C test coronary artery
calcification test not that expensive
not that invasive pretty quick but it
can give you a lot information of what's
going on inside of your arteries the
test score should be zero
but it can go over a thousand so let's
say for example you find out you have a
high score there's high amounts of
calcium clacking in your arteries well
there is a good solution to that
that's actually pretty natural that has
actually no side effects and it's taking
vitamin k2 if you're not familiar with
vitamin k2 I put a link down below but
it's a very very important vitamin that
can potentially remove the calcium from
your arteries and the type you want to
take is an MK 7 version between 200 and
300 micrograms every single day there's
some great data now what are you gonna
do if you're on warfarin and your doctor
is insisting that you stay on warfarin
well what I would recommend is getting
with your doctor and seeing if there's
another medication that you could take
that will do the same thing but still
allow you to consume vitamin k2 and if
that didn't work I would negotiate with
your doctor and see if you could
actually take vitamin k2 and take a
little bit more of this medication so at
least you would have absorption of
vitamin k2 to prevent the calcification
of your arteries now what are you gonna
do if you're in a diuretic
and you're trying to lower hypertension
now just so you know I'm not
recommending you to come off any of your
medications that's between you and your
doctor I would research taking 40,000 I
use a vitamin d3 and it would also
increase my potassium levels because our
bodies need about 4700 in most people
don't even get close and to do that you
would need to consume 7 to 10 cups of
vegetables per day and that would
greatly help you with this now as far as
cholesterol goes very simply you need to
get on a healthy keto diet and
intermittent fasting and that usually
should take care of that if you're new
to my channel I put a link down below
check it out Hey with another amazing
recipe no brains
no sugar totally keto
there's no suffering and Keita
absolutely no character and it's an
immune system builder absolutely you
have to check this out I think you
should hurry up watch the recipe and
make it yourself it's just so easy to be
Kido
what is it simple it's super simple we
hope you enjoy making it as much as we
are enjoying idioms